Now that you know a little bit more
about both write rules and validate
rules, you might be wondering what the
exact differences are between the two.
After all they are both executed when
you try to write data to a database.
Part of the difference is in their use.
Validation rules should be used to
ensure the correct structure and format
of data, whereas right rules deal with
who has access to write to that data.
Functionally, the fact that
write rules cascade down and
validate rules do not is very important.
Write rules should be used to map
out portions of the data structure
that particular users
have access to write to.
Whereas validate rules should be used
to deny a user with write access
if they're trying to do
something strange to the data.
Write rules therefore become
about giving access to someone.
Whereas validate rules can be used to
further restrict improper data editing.
For example, you could use a write rule
to say that a user could alter an item's
properties if they're the owner of
the list or shared on that list.
But say you want to also verify that
there are some true things specific
to each property, to make sure that
the property is being used correctly.
For example, you could validate
that they change the item
only to words that start
with capital letters.
Or you could do something like check
that the user is shopping at a list
if they want to edit the bought
property of an item.
And finally, another functional
difference that I've mentioned but
is very good to be again reminded of
is that validate rules are not executed
when something is deleted or removed.
And basically what this means is that
if you ever need to restrict access
to deleting or removing items, you'd
need to use the write rule for that.
Okay, hope that clears
things up a little bit.